Bon Merlin, je peux t'appeler Merluche ?
On va pas se mentir,
t'es l'un des acteurs les plus "bankable" du moment.
T'as joué dans les plus gros blockbusters américains.
J'crois pas avoir besoin de les rappeler, "Jurassic Cat", "Chavatar",
"SOS Souris", mes couilles,  mes couilles... Bref t'as une gueule
et moi j'ai envie de te voir sortir de ta zone de confort,
j'veux que tu t'mettes en danger,
et ton public veut ça.
Tu vois ça ? C'est ta carrière.
J'vais la faire exploser.
Le projet c'est celui-ci: "Chat en mission".
1000 pages de buzz.
Grosso merdo, on prévoit trois fois les entrées d'Avenger Endgame,
et j'imagine que tu meurs d'envie que je te pitch le scénario ?
En gros, si ce film devait avoir une bande-annonce,
ça commencerait comme ça.
Ecoute Merlin, je sais que t'as décroché, t'as refait ta vie,
ta carrière est derrière toi,
mais j'ai besoin de toi pour une nouvelle mission.
Il est de retour,
ton pire ennemi...
Freddy Fred.
Oui Merlin,
LE FREDDY FRED !!!!
Ai-je vraiment besoin de le rappeler?
celui qui a lâchement assassiné toute ta famille durant l'été 84,
notamment ton grand oncle Sergie.
Alors sac à puces ?
Tu continues à t'lécher le cul ou t'es prêt à reprendre du service ?
Alors, mission acceptée ?
Où est-ce que tu m'emmènes vieille branche ?
Oh, mais je crois que c'est la fameuse "Merlin Mobile" !
Tu l'avais gardée pendant toutes ces années !!
J'crois qu'elle a bien besoin d'un petit contrôle technique !
Cette fois Merlin, on peut dire que t'as été gâté !
Collier GPS, pare-balles, modificateur de miaulement avec caméra intégrée,
et évidemment, antipuces !
La célèbre souris grenade !
*Explosion*
Ça fait toujours un petit effet, *rire*
Et voici notre toute dernière trouvaille ! Merci Joël.
La chatière deux secondes !
Tu la poses sur n'importe quelle surface et hop, chatière.
*Grognement*
Et enfin, j'te présente la toute nouvelle "Merlin Mobile".
Lance-missiles latéraux, siège éjectable,
pneus à griffe pour monter aux arbres, blindage étanche en fibre de carbone,
projecteurs pour le MerlinSignal, radar anti-souris
et comme tu peux l'entendre, elle est bien sur équipée du tout nouveau moteur ronron v6.
Bon, par contre, pour la conduire il faut être titulaire du permis B.
Ah ah, j'déconne !
I'm just kidding, man.
Je pense pas qu'il bluffe !
Il a une quinte flush royale, c'est sûr !
Ok mon pote, c'est le moment d'utiliser ta vision nocturne de chat, je coupe le courant.
Qu'est ce qui se passe ?
*Musique suspense*
*Grognement*
*Musique de film d'action*
*Musique épique*
Bientôt au cinéma !
Alors t'en penses quoi ?
Bon écoute, le contrat est ici,
T'as juste à signer en bas avec ta pa-patte,
Et moi je m'occupe du reste.
Bon, dommage, The Rock le fera à ta place
Quand je pense qu'on parlait d'un cachet de plus de 200.000 croquettes de thon !